salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour obturer des la qualité
de votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à son filtre podcast à gmail point
com vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servez pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sf on s'assure que la qualité
était petit mal à tous les niveaux et
puis pour ramener votre projet le niveau
c'est vraiment la bonne chose à faire
alors écrivez-nous savoir plaisir de
vous recevoir ici production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités d'un supercanton avec moins
d'hommes blancs tu cette semaine il s'en
fut présentée par notre page piquionne
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous rejoindre sur pétrone depuis qu'on
a commencé à faire les encore moins de
filtres ou est-ce qu'on fait un après
chaud après les podcasts ou ce que deux
mois nicole on fait juste jazz et un peu
sur la conversation qu'ont et d'avoir
donc un genre de 20 à 30 minutes ou est
ce qu'on parle du pad ya ce qu'on vient
de tourner à chocques en convient le
tourner vous avez été beaucoup a réagi
vous aimez ça c'est le fun c'est comme
s'ils voulaient avoir accès à un contenu
exclusif la dirigez vous voir notre page
le lien est dans la description ci nomme
cette semaine sur le podcast cette
semaine sous le paillasson a reçu
juliette bélanger qui est étudiante en
criminologie et victimologie qui est
très actif sur les réseaux sociaux pour
les suivre sa page sur instagram
c'est vraiment super intéressant à
vulgarise des concepts qui nous aide à
comprendre plein plein de phénomènes de
ce qui justement de pardon tout ce qui a
rapport a fait ces temps-ci rapport aux
agressions sexuelles puis ça l'est
vraiment ça donne vraiment une
perspective vraiment intéressantes sur
toute la vague de dénonciations qu'ils
ont eue c'était vraiment du bon contenu
je vous invite à la suivre mais aussi d'
écouter le podcast qui s'en vient c'est
du fabricant version elle est très
documentaire connaissez affaire est
super intéressante est un grand plaisir
de les recevoir
ouais stéphane de parler de cette vague
dénonciation là avec un point de vue
plus académique le donc c'était du père
conversation on espère que vous allez
l'aimer autant que nous on a aimé la
voir si vous aimez ce que vous entendez
si vous voulez partager la bonne
nouvelle par les envois me abonnez vous
à nos chaînes laissé nu de times up les
cimes les commentaires pour nous dire
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de la
réflexion de la conversation puis se
sentent plus attendre bompas de quesques
bons échos
[Musique]
juliette
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté de venir
ici
si l'invitation fait plaisir plus que
jamais maintenant tonton champs
d'expertisé nécessaires
comment comment est ce que tu as vécu le
dernier mois comment ça a été pour toi
tu depuis le début de la vague de
dénonciations si on veut jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant parce que j'imagine que tu as
jamais été autant sollicité de ta vie le
nom non pitié moi mon au début ça fait
sept ans que sur instagram et que je
crée du contenu des jeux prend les
photos de café des photos de mon
environnement et il te plus en plus et
ça fait deux ans que je me dirige un
petit peu plus vers des discours qui
sont bons que ceux axés sur la santé
mentale sur le rapport au corps etc
et puis quand j'ai vu la vague de
dénonciations tranquillement le comme
prendre de l'ampleur j'ai vraiment eu de
la difficulté à peu donné mon npd s'est
directement directement exactement le
champ et dans lequel je me dirige mois
plus tard donc ça a été vraiment quand
même si je me retenais de même je me
suis dit à un moment donné imagine
certaines tribunes je l'utilisé je vais
voir ce que ça donne
cissé reçu ou non commencés le subit
comme de fait ça a été super bien reçu
faut que je continue hélas dans le pied
depuis s'arrête pas mais c'est c'est un
beau elle est une belle chose quand tu
parles de du domaine dans lequel tu
diriges le toit est étudiant en
criminologie way - dans le fond j'ai
fait un certificat j'ai fait plusieurs
choses toujours en relation des deux
mais là je me suis vraiment diriger
incrimine au j'ai fait un certificat
dans le fond je vais faire un bac par
cumul en études du phénomène criminel
qu'est paul équipe a le bac incrimine au
mas qui rassemble fixé plusieurs
certificats d'actes mans là je vais
faire le mélange toujours un majeur puis
minar mais je vais faire deux un crime
unodc et une majeure je crois qu'entre
deux ans que deux incriminés puis un an
victime qui était certificat dans le
fond c'est quoi la noix sont victimes
aux logiques criminologie
ben essentiellement c'est que ça a l'air
super de voir quelle somme c'est une
vraie bonne question parce que dans le
fond un crime nous on veut vraiment
s'intéresser au contact de
réhabilitation et comment dans le fond
dans une trajectoire de vie quelqu'un a
pu en venir à avoir un mode de vie
criminelle à commettre des gestes
criminels
on va vraiment s'intéresser bon à la
personne comme tel au profil
psychologique mais aussi de plus haut au
profil de comment on traite la
criminalité finalement et en tant que
société puisque c'est essentiellement un
peu la même chose en victimologie mais
vraiment axé sur la victime sur les
dents le fond les comment travailler
dans un contexte traumatique ou si
vraiment c'est une autre type
complètement de la proche mais c'est
vraiment axé sur la victime comme pulp
évidemment teillé des liens en fer entre
les jets et on on exclut souvent qu'une
personne je veux un délinquant mais ça
sonne canal d un contrevenant mais
délinquants souvent il ya dix ya un
certain passé traumatique ou six points
sur compte de plus en plus donc il ya
des liens à faire il ya des
vulnérabilités aussi qui font en sorte
que tu peux passer d'être une personne
victime puis finalement commettre des
gestes criminels ou si ça excuse henry
le commun des gestes
bon ça va mettre comprendre d'où ça
vient exactement exactement ça permet
d'avoir certaines avenues au plan
thérapeutique ou cias non j'imagine ça
t'amène avons une perspective quand même
d'empathie le fasse justement au aux
contrevenants
oui parce qu'elle est le but finalement
la finalité c'est sid et régler ces
problèmes le bouc succès arrive ce ben
oui pis pour qui la réhabilitation fo
qui est en partie il faut qu' un certain
système autour de la personne qui est
qui soutenant qu'il ya une certaine dans
la mesure du possible une compréhension
qu'un désir de compréhension pour qui
est vraiment un changement qui soit
amorcée je lisais nos publications que
tu avais fait dans la manche demain en
expliquant que souvent les
les criminels avaient un passé justement
de victimes mais la nuance qui est
amenée c'était vraiment ce que tu
viennes dire là de dire ça excuse en
rien puis on le vu énormément dans les
derniers dernières semaines cette espèce
de discours là deux parce que moi je
vois pas bien je suis comme un des actes
puissent comme une espèce de façon de me
déculpabiliser deux seuls tirs notamment
dans l'excusent initiale je pense de
julien c'était souvent de dire non mais
je vois tellement pas bien je vois
tellement pas bien puis au final ça
change rien les tuer maintenant ça
change rien et puis elle a limité même
si on pose plus loin mais c'est si la
personne victime dénonce puisque le son
son agresseur dit oui mais j'étais dans
un contexte où j'allais vraiment pas
bien où je me sentais pas je sais pas
moi j'étais j'avais un problème de
j'étais dépressif et gérable et je ne
consommer consommer notamment mais ça
fait en sorte ça peut faire en sorte que
la personne victime de dire à barack est
ce que c'est vraiment tout d'abord que
j'ai perçu travaux remettent en question
peut-être éventuellement sa version des
faits puis avoir de la compassion pour
son agresseur skip une mauvaise chose en
soi dans une optique de reprise de
pouvoir personnel mais ça pue ça peut
finalement faire en sorte qu'ils aient
la victime phase durable et j'ai tout
bien fait de dénoncer plus encore une
fois il va revoir certaines certaine
culpabilité peut-être à la dénonciation
de par le fait de se dire
- c'est vrai qu'ils étaient pas bien
c'est vrai c'est peut-être moi qui a peu
mal agi en ce moment là j'aurais pas dû
voir qui allait pas bien c'est j'aurais
dû plus puis l'un des sacs ça finalement
ça repose un peu la victime en position
de déculpabilisation finale
quand tu parles de reprise de pouvoir
personnel de quoi est-ce que tu pas ben
ça peut ça peut avoir toutes sortes de
formes la main souvent sinon un angle
qu'on va prendre avec les victimes comme
tel quant à quand une victimisation
quand il
un acte criminel ou même une agression
et un espèce de con croit en un monde
juste et équitable de manière générale
entre nous c'est à dire que bon après on
lutte pour plusieurs choses mais l'idée
étant que pour qu'on soit capable de
sortir de chez nous qui conçoit en
confiance qu'il ya personne qui vont
nous attaquer qu'éthique bon témoin
c'est chez le dentiste jean sparowes
position de vulnérabilité je ne sais que
le dentiste va être professionnel j'ai
pas partie on a cette espèce de
confiance avec lequel nécessaires à un
bon fonctionnement social oui
puis c'est extrêmement confrontant de se
dire que c'est possible que ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui s'en prennent à nous donc
on préfère t ne pas y penser
puis quand yeux acte criminel cryer
agression ce que ça fait c'est que ça
viendront finalement ce que ce lien de
confiance là en l'humanité salengro
d'une main mais c'est vraiment se tait
parce qu' on se dit à québec non
seulement c'est possible que quelqu'un
de par le caractère intentionnel la
chose s'en prennent à moi mais en plus
je peux 4 ogi pas été capable guillemets
de m'assurer sécurité de m'assurer
protection parce que bon il ya des
différents mécanismes de protection très
très très très instinctif qu'on peut pas
prévoir le fameux frire ce fonds de
figer faire face donc c'est un peu cette
idée quand il ya une espèce de on perd
notre pouvoir personnalité à ce moment
le pire une perte de confiance non
seulement les autres mais en soit aussi
c'est ce qui fait en sorte aussi que
quand on reçoit une dénonciation de
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'est super
confrontant de croire directement la
victime parce que de croire que c'est
possible
cette croire que ça peut peut-être
éventuellement nous arriver aussi accès
à ces ultras confrontant parce que ça
vient jouer dans les balises et plus
profond de notre sentiment de sécurité
personnelle il est impersonnelle
finalement donc pour répondre à la
question
ben c'est vraiment d'aller chercher
finalement d'aider des voix pour
reprendre un certain sentiment de
reprise de pouvoir personnel parce que
ça peut passer par punch aux il y en a
pour qui par exemple les excuses ou
le contact avec l'agresseur ça va être
une certaines avenues pour reprendre
certaines reprises de pouvoir il y en a
pour qui le fait jamais pardonné
l'agresseur savez tous y ait une reprise
de pouvoir personnel
bon il ya la justice réparatrice souci
qui quitte une belle avenue également
mais bon ya toutes sortes de moyens si
c'est vraiment la victime ou la
survivante le selon comment il préférait
s'est autoproclamé qui qui va choisir
selon ses besoins aussi selon le
caractère du geste aussi l'agression et
et puis quand quand tu parles quand tu
dis que cette espèce de perte de pouvoir
là c'est un peu la raison pour laquelle
quand ce qu'on soit le témoignage d'une
agression qu on le lit on sent un peu
décalé parce qu'on sait comme une
nouvelle possibilité qui à paraître
c'est fini je vais extrapoler un petit
peu mais j'imagine que c'est une des
raisons pourquoi juste pour un une
tierce personne qui regardait tout ça
allait mais tant qu homme comme nous le
dit oui pourquoi ça a été si difficile
les dernières semaines et je peux même
pas imaginer le tue je veux dire je
parle je parle la bouche pleine de même
pas imaginer comment c'était hadj est
difficile pour une survivante
sauf que ça a été difficile même pour
moitié même pour nous c'est probablement
une des raisons j'imagine pourquoi les
spartakistes était comme ma quille c'est
tellement arrivé tellement d'instance ou
est ce qu'il ya une agression qui est
commise dans un monde où est ce que
peut-être ton passé pop qui en avait
c'est extrêmement confronté à tous les
niveaux que c'est d'accepter que ça
existait un peu comme mon ami coureurs
on parlait de culture de viol puis on
est tous des étudiants qui se ment
victimologie donc en principe la culture
du violon devrait être à même de bien à
comprendre d'enseignants c'est tout puis
avait énormément de gorki qui est
incapable de dire en cours de
harcèlement est criminel
puis il y avait plusieurs groupes
malheureusement c'est bon il ya
peut-être 4 go dans mes classes à chaque
fois plus que tout les gars qui disait
qu'il ne savait pas de sens si dans le
fond il contestait un peu plusieurs
concepts la culture du viol
c'est l'addiction qu'on avait c'est à
dire ben peut-être que d'accepter que ça
existe la culture du viol c'est
peut-être aussi accepter qu'on y
contribuer d'une certaine manière vous
donnons tcc confrontant on et porn de la
difficulté à avoir une image comme ça de
nous t on à tout une image de ce conte
et de ce qu'on projette puis quand on
voit dans ces zones la baisse
extrêmement inconfortable
le mot viol justement est un mot qui est
extrêmement inconfortable wi fi qui est
extrêmement fort justement chargé
puisque pour ce que le terme plutôt des
viols rebute où tant de gens j'ai
l'impression mais des couacs on parle
exactement quand on parle la culture du
viol
ouais parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qu'on ait une expression qu'on
l'entend souvent monsieur normand on
veut mais des pistes est normal que peu
de encore d'être il ya des tentatives de
définition culture du viol exact mais je
pense que c'est tellement un compte
quelque chose qui est à la fois abstrait
puis à la fois que ce qui se matérialise
dans plein de petits détails mais je
pense que c'est l'idée de rejeter
finalement et commencerait bien acheté
le véhicule des victimes racheter l'idée
que possibilité de victimisation pu
minimiser les impacts d'une
victimisation les banaliser les tasses
et du revers de la main par des des
réactions qui sont très très très
instinctive malheureusement il s'est
peut-être ses côtés instinctif l'oeuf
dans le mans qui caractérise un peu la
culture du vieux en quelque sorte et moi
on m'a déjà essayé de m'embrasser compte
mon grieg puis à dans un contexte amical
et
puis les amis de filles autour de moi me
disait mais non m ils connaissent des
destins dans ma famille sous saisie tu
vas voir il se rappelle rapidement et
puis puis ça dans le fond ce que ça dit
c'est ben pas québec - d'abord ma
réaction à la peau lieu d'être
finalement c est donc on banalise ma
réaction de cépie ses collègues de jeudi
rillieux une gravité des agressions à
caractère sexuel sur une échelle de
gravité absolument they may a pas
d'échelle ya pas de hiérarchisation des
réactions entre un et six mois quand
même bien que je me fais donne une tape
sur les fesses dans le métro ça se peut
que j'aie un état de stress post
traumatique après c'est pas à banaliser
ce n'est pas un nom de choisir
finalement et quelle agression on devra
avoir devrait générer quelle réaction de
ses fans
puis j'imagine que tu es dans os qu on
prend chaque un port à cette culture le
savent eux aussi aller dans l'est dans
les plus petits détails des anecdotes
anodine ou est ce que par exemple j'ai
un million d'exemplaires de go dans un
vestiaire qui qui qui parle ni en est ce
qu ils disent n'importe quoi mais tout
c'est toutes ces choses là
par rapport à mai ton l'objectif ication
d'une femme de qu'est ce qu'on ferait un
8 10 watts c'est le genre de
commentaires qui pourraient qui
contribuent en fait à banaliser certains
actes qui sont des agressions entre ben
oui absolument absolument
il ya vraiment un outil c'est qu'on fait
rendu compte avec ce mouvement le c'est
l'omniprésence justement des agressions
sexuelles de l'alliance technologique où
justement des propos misogynes où tu
sais c'est qu'ils à quel point sépare
toupie dans un certain degré toutes les
femmes en sont victimes les toits c'est
cela le plus grand constat des sites
histoire de pi et ce qui est plus dur en
tant que société pas en tant qu'homme
aussi à réaliser c'est que sans doute
que d'une certaine manière un certain
degré j'ai contribué à sortir puis le qu
est ce qu on doit collectivement et
personnellement et collectivement
gd apprendre modifier nos comportements
pour quelqu'un comme ça se fait aussi un
contexte et ses duels dans un vestiaire
j'imagine de 0,6 tout le monde de cette
énergie l'aude de fantasmer sur une
feuille ça doit être dur d'être le
groupe faire est minuté y essayer moyen
était de parler d'elle différemment
c'est confrontant mais c'est à force
justement d'aller à contre un verre
c'est finalement à contresens que
finalement ça pue utile d articuler
certains et j'ai l'impression que ce
mouvement-là va avoir fait exactement
sur steam mettons moi je me serais
vraiment pas bien vu à être celui qui
fait heilige comme cette filiale est
aussi un par allociné c'est aussi ça
fait ici sauf que en ce moment j'ai
l'impression que ça risque d'être
beaucoup plus sensibles au même titre
que avec le mouvement black light madère
où est ce que le un commentaire raciste
qui passe sur le thread il passera plus
anxieux laitiers ou du moins il va
beaucoup moins passé j'ai l'impression
que ça va peut-être avoir contribué à ce
oui oui aussi beaucoup plus et je pense
que c'est aussi ça va avoir contribué à
une meilleure reconnaissance
moi c'est ce pourquoi je lutte
quotidiennement d'une meilleure
reconnaissance des besoins généraux et
spécifiques des victimes t on je pense
aux excuses dans ce moment si c'est
normal il ya beaucoup dénonciation qui
se font et puis c'est normal je dire sur
des personnes qui s'en est publique
puis bin de par le caractère public de
la chose on est habitué de les voir un
peu partout ces personnes là autant dans
leur salon sur instagram que dans notre
télé donc on s'attend finalement
accueilli il ya des excuses qui est des
autres comme une justification mais
essentiellement préférablement des
excuses et on se rend compte combien le
choix des mots dont ses excuses le est
extrêmement est sensible dans un
contexte de victimes l'injecter ya
beaucoup de mocky qui peuvent avoir un
caractère de victimisation second darty
la victimisation secondaire je te le
phénomène omniprésent en victimologie
c'est l'idée que puis à l'essai
en parler tout récemment aussi souvent
dans ce que je lis dans les études c'est
ben c'est plus la victime veut dire
servir constamment va dire c'est pot
temps le trou noir comme tel maintenant
qui m'habite c'est toutes les réactions
ensuite c et puis tout le processus
autant judiciaire que bon les réactions
que j'ai une mes proches c'est sûr que
quand un proche qui remet en question sa
version des faits ou quand tu dis mais
voyons dompter tablier commun ou c'est
aussi c'était un truc normal si on veut
on veut comprendre c'était quoi le
contexte pour digérer finalement un peu
la teneur traumatique la chose
ils mangent ici je vais te fallait
d'alice justement tipi une chose qu'elle
a dit qu'ils nous avaient remarqué pind
vraiment rentrer dedans c'était tout à
mal le fait que est le traumatisme de la
dénonciation était plus important que
l'agression comme tel c'est difficile
d'annoncer utile et toutes les mais elle
a le vécu parce que la maquette et au
bac français est attaqué à couy mais
c'est ça je peux pas imaginer la
difficulté que ça doit être surtout de
le faire publiquement mais tentons donc
ton visage de la banquise louis qui à
chaque fois dit ce que les personnes qui
disent quand ils disent mais dire qu'est
ce qui est arrivé et toubon qui
remettent en question finalement ton
rôle dans la victimisation à chaque fois
ci une certaine trahison c'est une
certaine surtout quand c'est des proches
c'est comme un certain abandon tissé de
farouk et moi je cherche un soutien
cherche une validation mes émotions
autant une validation de l'événement ce
sera autre chose d'une validation de mes
réactions traumatique de mes besoins
puisque tu me dises c'est moins acquis
mais tu étais tu est en couple avec ou
et puis je sais pas moi tu étais tu
flirter avec ou peut-être valeur
intéressé au début tu es souvent on va
avoir tendance à remettre sur la victime
finalement le fardeau de sa
victimisation puis dans les excuses on
le voit beaucoup beaucoup se tait puis
dans le fait aussi de se
déresponsabiliser via le fait que bon
j'avais un problème de santé mentale
jeter dans une relation toxique paquet
où il était mais si tu es capable
d'identifier que la relation toxique
dans laquelle tu étais avait un impact
sur toi mais tu es capable d'identifier
aussi que t'es con
tellement un impact sur les victimes des
faits que c'est tout seul le choix des
mots aussi est intéressante qui peuvent
par fils de victimisation aussi
essentiellement été le fait de dire si
oui mais jeter jeu des mineurs
à titre d'exemple et baisse fait
agresser quelqu'un non non cette excuse
le dont on parle pour moi est le
contre-exemple parfait n'excuse tri de
tous les points tous les choses à ne pas
faire une excuse sera concentrée le prix
pilote le déconstruit petit l'analyser
petit déclic et métiers juste à ma
tentative de décrédibiliser
décrédibiliser le mouvement en tant que
tel de se déresponsabiliser de pitié les
deux si j'ai blessé je m'excuse métier
il n'y a pas de si le yen de personnes
discutent en compte par le conditionnel
qui
mais oui c'est ça c'est vraiment il y en
a vu beaucoup d' excuses admis demi
excuses le haut des dons à demi mot il
ya neuf mois beaucoup justement pour
essayer de minimiser sa personne dans ce
que de le comparer qui est celle de
julien site est tellement flagrant que
je pense qu'il ya peu de sympathie pour
ses excuses à mes méthodes d'autres
excuses
par exemple j'aime pas ce métier mettons
les excuses de marie-pierre il y avait
de ça mais c'était plus et mieux
camoufler dans celle de malepère avait
été écrit par quelqu'un dont c'est du
lien avec terry par lui la personne
d'été etc en fait partie et l'équipe de
pays auraient fait main c'est un chrono
s'allumant mais moi en quelque sorte tu
t'es content qu'il ait pas demandé à son
équipe
parce que je me dis bon ok voilà témoins
voici exactement comme s'ils disaient un
bon contre exemple utilisons le puits
apprenons de sept de ses contres
exemples finalement mais justement si je
disais de ne pas tenter de reprendre
justement sa publication que tout prix
c'est sa première excuse la première
version qui est faite de à chaud c'est
vraiment intéressant de voir de
décortiquer un texte comme celui là de
façon académique
oui c'est ça tu fais de chacun des
passages et pour ceux qui qui qui savent
pas ici de qu'on parle on peut aller sur
ton compte instagram pour pourvoir cette
publication d'autres acteurs c'est que
tu prends chacun des passages tu l'aidés
construit de façon académique oublie ça
permet de vraiment bien comprendre les
mécanismes desquels on parle en ce
moment c'est un exemple parfait de woods
qui ont trait qui a écrit ça pour que ce
soit un exemple parfait des différents
mécanismes des agresseurs des excuses
agresseurs exactement petit mois ce
qu'est ce que je voulais dire aussi à
travers tout ça c'est justement bon
encore une fois le choix des moins
importants mais c'est pas parce que je
peux parce qu'une faute est à vous et
qui est à moitié pardonnée aussi on aime
beaucoup le barbon facile de dire ok
mais là il s'est excusé
tu devrais peut-être le pardonne un thé
mais dans une excuse comme soit aussi
rapidement force est de constater que
c'est l'idée de finalement de cars mais
l'espèce de besoins d'appréhension qu'on
ad'abord des excuses et justification
c'est un peu pour finalement faire
shine et en ligne ou en tout cas
soulager l'image publique la personne et
est ce que vraiment les besoins des
victimes sont entendus dans ses excuses
là je pense pas que je pense pas que ce
serait possible parce que pour ceux
fauquet réelle reconnaissance du
problème typique pour qu'il y ait un
changement qui soit vraiment en mille de
manière vraiment dans une optique de
réhabilitation des phoques et
reconnaissance que s'il y avait eu
reconnaissance eh ben ça serait pas
renouvellé pas eu ces dénonciations le t
il ya ça aussi tu es de l'idée que ce
pas parce qu'il ya une excuse publique
ou non que la personne victime est
obligé
par l'onu paul le pardon n'est pas
garant finalement d'une raie par deux
sentiments de retour de pouvoir
personnel ça appartient à chaque victime
sont c'est quelque chose qu'on entend
souvent finalement de dire comme bon
mais il s'est excusé c'est comme c'est
un peu et on s'excuse on apprend aux
enfants à s'excuser rapidement déjà
parlé de ça avec une thérapeute ou cités
on a on apprend l'excusé traîne et
fauqué quelque chose vraiment que ce
soit en temps mais derrière ce démarche
d'excusés lot il faut qu'il ya des
démarches réel de réhabilitation qui
soit fait pour les raisons intrinsèques
parce que c'est fait pour des raisons
extra c'est qu'à ce moment-là sarpaux
d'impacter ou long terme
première étape justement recueille la
reconnaissance puis mettons danser
encore une fois on sait que cet exemple
d' excuse le ont senti qu'ils étaient
même pas rendu à cette étape notamment
de reconnaître l'état mais puisque c'est
une première étape vers après ceux ci
justement quand on parlait des des
raisons justement maria de ce qui
n'excuse pas mais qui peuvent expliquer
dans des comportements 6,6 parce qu'ils
étaient des problèmes de dépression et
même des consommations tout ce b les
footeux y travailler là dessus et vous
ne réglez ce fauteuil en thérapie pitié
tant qu'à moi si si c'est ici si toutes
ces étapes le son fait peut-être que le
pardon plus facilement 50
català pas la certitude mais qu'à taux
au moins là une preuve qu' il ya une
démarche qui fait piquer dans le fond tu
es comportement ils vont ils restent de
sincérité
si tu es je pense que la plupart des
victimes ce qu'ils veulent avant tout
c'est qu'il y en ait pas d'autres mais
c'est qui est non si c'est sec qui ne
reconnaît sans problème puis une
reconnaissance des réactions au site et
de dire que oui je reconnais que bon
j'ai agi d'une manière exclusive
mais je reconnais aussi que jeter causer
du tort et je vais faire en sorte que ça
arrive plus non seulement toi mais que
ça arrive plus à d'autres personnes
aussi celle que je vois moi surtout non
lésés dans les excuses c'est l'étape de
pré contemplation juste avant changement
c'est à dire qui est la personne votre
reer accueille oui j oui j'ai un
comportement problématique si c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'étape du oui mais mais
c'est un peu l'étape de come back
juste avant elle en fait c'est comme
entre le déni puis l'étape de
reconnaissance de prix de
doyon de l'associé prise de
responsabilité merci puis c'est dans ton
c'est ça c'est comme il contemple le
problème mais c'est oui mais j'allais
pas bien oui mais j'étais dans un
contexte où il y avait jeté en boisson
mettewie mettez plus est un peu sorti
mais ce set cette étape cruciale parce
que il est malléable
donc c'est là que ya moyen de faire
acquis oui mais il ya une certaine
ouverture mais travaillons sur cette
ouverture la de sorte que tu sois même
si c'est un petit peu plus incriminés le
meilleur de soi même de reconnaître
finalement qui a un problème comme
encontre est une autre question je pose
est bien mais tais-toi justement dit en
criminologie justement d'essayer de
comprendre la psychologie derrière les
gens qui font commettre des actes comme
ce qu'on va marquer beaucoup de gens qui
ont des taux de personnalités
oui par exemple d'enceinte et leurs 6 pi
fallait qu'une amie qui quittent au
doctorat en psychologie palissy cesser
ces troubles hausse et les choses les
plus difficiles à traiter parce que la
reconnaissance des torts et parfois
presque impossible pour certaines
personnes c'est vrai qu il est une épice
question qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
quelqu'un qui aurait vraiment d'être et
de pervers narcissique loin végéter j'ai
eu un cours de psychopathie j'ai eu un
cours de justement des troubles de
personnalité et pis ça commence à être
long et là dans ma mémoire ça que je
serai vraiment bonne pour vraiment
donner des pistes exact mais maitient un
trouble de personnalité si c'est
vraiment dans la personnalité c'est un
peu comme si je te demandais de voir la
table brune puis te dire la brune puis à
dire ben non faut que tu la vois noir
c'est comme si ceux ci c'est extrêmement
difficile
il ya des moyens le vraiment plus
d'équipés un criminologue passerait plus
c'est pour mieux vous le dire que moi
mais il ya des moyens de le faire mais
c'est extrêmement petit et on lui chargé
de cours le disent tout le temps c'est
comme tu es quand il ya quelqu'un qui
est un trouble de personnalité
c'est comme attachez votre tuque le
stonegate est fou c'est dur de l'amener
finalement reconnaître qu'un problème
parce que liée comme ce pays
mais il ya possibilité de changement
bien évidemment mais ça prend beaucoup
plus d'efforts le puits de temps ça
ça amène à réfléchir à la suite des
choses pour tout les agresseurs qui ont
été quand l'ordre qui ont pris un recul
par rapport à la sphère publique ça
amène vraiment les questionnements à se
dire est ce que il ya réhabilitation
possible comment est ce par quoi ça va
passer de seppi puis on le dit tout à
l'heure on a quand même les le pardon
facile
pis pour surtout une certaine
démographie peut-être peut-être plus
vieille peut-être moins éveillé aux
enjeux sociaux j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses qui vont passer
très rapidement le tir puis je sais pas
comment c'est je sais pas par quoi ça
peut passer la réhabilitation de ces
gens là tu sais ce que tout ces gens là
sont juste maintenant c'est juste
terminée et et ben moi je préfère manger
pendant ce passeport je pense que la
majorité dit que car ici si c'est un
problème ici des problèmes autres que
des principes à salt et le thé de
l'éducation pays où c'est juste le fait
que ce soit tellement de normaliser
banalisée omniprésent que que si si on
reconnaît pas la gravité est il du truc
et il ya plein de formes d'agressions
qui était il faut revoir notre notre
image de ce qui est l'agression sexuelle
d'inconduite sexuelle c'est parce que
beaucoup de choses qui c'est qui qui qui
dans la sphère de abc des blagues ou à
6,6 possesseurs blanc c'est pas grave
facétie si on commence par revoir ce
complètement puis d'apprendre que bat
plus pour enlever ton condom en une
relation sexuelle peut juste faire de
quoi
c'est un move un petit peu plus avancé
faire poser la question à 20,6 car elle
quitte à faire là bas même si y'a dit
les choses à mâcon à canossa wii fit et
je pense qu'elle est enfin la
réhabilitation mais il ya un travail
énorme de prévention à faire ces pistes
ce que vous en avez parlé souvent mais
ça passe par l'éducation sexuelle
éducation adaptée et et moi et mon
souvenir puis vous en parliez aussi avec
à l'essai était mon souvenir c'est une
banane futur c'est mon prof d'éthique
qui me prenait une bande en armes et un
condom c'était plus traumatisant
qu'autre chose qu'on a demandé nous
pillons par les dts et si on parlait de
on parlait de la section la sexualité de
manière très négative ou t on disait
mais si tu mets pas de condom tu vas pas
pouvoir dont l'adresse est pas comme
étant quelque chose de multi
dimensionnelle tant pis je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est ultra
importante et 2 c'est évidemment dans la
culture viol il ya énormément t on
apprend puis de plus en plus le lit les
jeunes ont accès à des tablettes à des
jeux parlement comme quelqu'un de très
bien en ce moment mais on est établie
depuis des téléphones il donc qu'ils ont
accès facilement à de la pornographie
c'est comme ça finalement qu'ils
apprennent c'est quoi les comportements
avoir pu force est de constater que dans
la pornographie mais c'est l'homme
souvent que c'est l'idée du fantasme de
l'homme qui est entreprenant qui 75% des
vidéos de pornographie cette agression
mais c'est ça a été vraiment dur parce
que toujours un rapport de pouvoir le
très exactement qui s'est valorisé c'est
la filiale a l'air d'aimer 110 métier y
comme toute une mécanique au site et ça
se termine toujours par l'homme et c'est
rare qu'on voit une femme avoir un
orgasme et où entre que c'est un vrai
fac et factures tout ça aussi on apprend
finalement beaucoup de ces pratiques le
et puis c'est très très très très
accessible puis ben évidemment mais ça
fait en sorte qu'il ya des pratiques la
dengue qui sont reprises après dans les
premières relations sexuelles puis
autant la fille qui est garçon s'y
essaye d affaire.c puis les deux c'est
autant gars on va essayer des trucs
l'afrique sera peut-être pas là et puis
on sait on
je pense que l'éducation sexuelle qu'il
nie ces salles en ce moment c'est
vraiment parler du consentement c'est
moi je moi dans ma tête ça fait si je
vais le consentement c'est d'abord ce
qui est mais si c'est dans ma part est
en moi de fille qui étudie la bunge jour
et nuit
mais j'entendais une fille lotois qui me
disait c'est ben moi je pleure si j'ai
figé qu'est-ce que tu n'auras réaction
tout à fait normal a dit j'ai figé mais
je pleurais tpiy le goy continue et puis
il ya des gens mais tu es j'étais
consentante je me dis que la fille après
un moment donné ça prend portée mais
après c'est savoir à qui était est-ce
qu'il ya peu peut-être après subsiste
une autre question qu'est-ce qui a pas
un conte un certain pouvoir la densité
qui t'a société peut-être que la
personne qui agressait sexuellement 7
fait le cd mais peut-être qu'un certain
plaisir aussi dans l'idée de prendre
pouvoir sur quelqu'un c'est un non sujet
ça tombe un petit peu plus dans la
déviance mais encore le t1 dans la
pornographie on les voit ces
comportements le encore de prendre
pouvoir sur l'autre que ce soit sexy que
ce soit de l'ordre du fantasme i to
fakie et où tu sais je pense que tout ça
déconstruire un dans les cours
d'éducation sexuelle s'il y en a un jour
qui sont adaptés c'est de prendre les
vraies questions des personnes qui de
partir de ça de construire de ceux des
cours qui sont vraiment vraiment adéquat
et qui répondent aux vraies questions
t2c moins jeunes aussi on avait eu le
droit de poser des questions en nous
mêmes sur des papillons se cachait plus
en écumant des questions évidemment il
va toujours de niaiseries mais il y
avait une question qui est arrivé c'est
à dire est ce que je suis obligé de
recevoir finalement l'éjaculation dans
les usages c'est pis c'est tout
en même temps on avait 14 ans était tout
comme si c'est en tête ont un peu mal à
l'aise
une vraie question qui est adressée tu
dire mais disent ça dépend si toi tu
veux ça dépend si c'est vraiment des
chances de laisser la place aussi
vraiment à ce qu'on comprenne c'est quoi
le consentement de dans ces bases les
plus profondes et puis moi je trouve ça
super beau t'es un gars qui j'ai partagé
hier un extrait de normes aux pipots qui
est une une série qui est adressée
essentiellement aux adolescents pis aux
jeunes adultes
puis tout le long de la seine d'intimité
dit lui demander toutes sortes de
questions puis sarsar empochera quoi et
de l'été au contraire ça rend ce sexy à
la limite et sus d'un autre problème qui
se soit sexy que le consentement soit 9
et 10 mai mais au moins tu es si c'est
ce qui peut permettre de faire en sorte
que ça va être un petit peu plus
acquitter temps doux et moelleux juste
le concept du consentement ou le mot
concernant mes pommes pas été enseigné
avant vraiment longtemps le tijou
première fois que j'ai entendu parler de
consentement c'est sûr qu'à évidemment
je dors je peu débile le concept
n'existait le dis dans ma tête ça il
fallait que les deux parties soient
partageront des relations sexuelles mais
mais le concept du consentement tnine
pis jusqu'où ça vote
parce que oui veut du concret ensemble
oui ou non c'est du consentement mais ça
va vraiment plus loin que ce n'est
toutes ses nuances peuple s'est étendu
le mois jamais été enseigné
jamais jamais jamais jamais théo comme
comme toi tu irais seconde as tu es
vraiment plus main kornhaus non tu mens
merci beaucoup
mais oui si vous apprendra consentement
au système on parle peu du consentement
dans une relation de complicité
on parle pas du consentement d'une
position sexuelle en particulier d'une
pratique sexuelle le consentement est
tellement plus large va tellement plus
loin que veux tu faire l'amour oui non
partagé fakir pinon petit petit moteur à
prendre aussi aiguisé notre non verbale
aiguisé en fait notre notre lecture et
on remercie de non verbale t2 mais cela
fait affiche la fia a fait aucun bruit a
fait aucun paiement imprimés vraiment
affiches mais ya matière à se pose des
questions et matière arrêtée puis de
faire à temps minuté têtu consentants
toutes et tous à ton petit youtube on
prend une pause outils comme je suis
moins être à l'écouté vraiment des
signaux de la personne lui
qu'est-ce que l'a5 été décrite en tout
la fille pleure je peux concevoir que
faut vraiment être nullement dans fait
complètement dans le déni me fais comme
si tu avais pas contre le propos mais
continue dans une situation comme ça
parce que ça n'a aucun bon sens oui mais
moi ma question son intérêt ce sera même
question personnelle mais je me dis et
ayez est où ton phone tennant s'en
soucie vraiment la fille ap leurs pieds
c'est ce que vous aviez l'oeil peut être
matière à aller voir tu es dans ton
profil
qu'est ce qui se passe pour les faits du
plaisir et qui soit capable d'être
excités un même si la fille est
complètement pas consentante ou city
mais c'est le concept du dit oui
enthousiaste
oui c'est ça amène un espèce de c'est
pas normal si on est souvent la note
soit dans les films saw d'aller dans les
histoires australie
lille est ce qu ont été exposés à
l'autre l'histoire est de 2 à la team et
on l'a la femme la fille voulait pas au
début mes tripes j'ai percé v
rédiger les comptes il a changé d'idée
pinana puis ça c'est vu comme un genre
de romantisme absolument ouais pis on
dit que la lumière du convaincant ce
n'est pas du romantisme c'est juste cuit
plus jocelyn prix et pot into your job
losses le morceau c'est absolument
aucune différence entre les fleuves et
tes jeux des îles bon oeil un peu avant
une certaine game le tchèque qui encore
une fois c'est l'idée d'être de savoir
la liberté de dire ok bon et c'est à
cette dynamique de couple lors de cette
dynamique de personnes vont un petit
game de jeu quand je m'écarte si je veux
dire est ce pas bannie mais là où c'est
vraiment de fait d'insister espèce
d'idée du du chasseur pidgeon comme on
appelle cela les animaux qui s'est pris
la tête de la proa est exactement dit ce
soutien d'affaires sait s'il faut
vraiment insiste c'est puis je trouve ça
même peu valorisante une enceinte
cultive ses sorties vers des fixes vont
vraiment vouloir de toi tennant
essentielle ça aussi un peu aimée mais
oui il ya un univers fantasmagorique
autour de cette seule idée que que la
fille qui l'a petit roitelet finalement
qui était filmé le sur netflix en ce
moment qui s'appelle trois quines naples
a fait puis 1 1 pourrait si la parcours
banane mois et jusqu'à quel point est-ce
qu'ils m'aident flex ils ont la tête
d'un cul pour pouvoir se lever c'est
cette c'est moi j'en ai parlé puisque
encore long a plongé dans grande
disponibilité
j'ai lutté comme j'ai pu à travers ma
forme mais pg il ya une pétition et tour
420 pimpi mettons l'issue du film la
conclusion si qui finirent heureux et
eurent beaucoup d'enfants se trouvent
six mètres aux abords du ring
ces six athlètes ont finalement condamné
maintenance et puis que la morale comme
ah ouais c'est quelque chose - longtemps
c'est alexandre jardin c'est un de mes
auteurs préférés le pi un moss mon livre
préféré l'action jardin ça s'appelle
fanfan puis dans fanfan legayic court
après fanfan qui est une femme à qui
puis l aveu pratiquement rien savoir de
lui tient mais on y loue l'appartement
et c'est tellement une scène il loue
l'appartement
c'est ultra romantique été le
protagoniste et il trouve à l'origine il
loue l'appartement à côté de fanfan
pendant qu'un parti
barak est parti il transforme le mur en
miroir qui voit juste d'un côté la
suisse prend même à côté d'or il passe
sa journée à tous se promener à côté de
fanfan sans qu'elle le sache c'est un
clic pilote hills a fini le les finis
qui au final mans il couche avec fanfan
eu à mener afin il décide de ces partis
mais là tu dis ta barre m à quel point
est-ce que c'est loin pour que ce genre
si le comportement le plus cru agressant
entraînant un criminel de l'histoire
c'est quelqu'un qui qui qui y dalaï
légumes et des eaux la réalité est il de
la deûle entre higuain qui donne le ton
avec son jardin ils suffisent à son
romantisme qui se dit ah mais je dois
appliquer ça ma vie mais 90% des
protagonistes d'alexandre jardin si
c'est des agresseurs grippe selon leur
vision de la relation est dérangé dit
mettons le faire des espèces de geste
romantique comme ça over de top
il ya deux affaires si la personne alain
oui enthousiaste comme tu dis c'est
romantique ou si la personne à la mini
réserve c'est extrêmement grippe infecte
et ça j'ai l'impression qu'il soit aussi
dans toute la culture la culture
populaire qu'on consomme
il y aussi cette espèce de relation
l'aude valoriser les actes romantique
qui au final si on en reparle encore
john cusak ldans tu le fais moi ce qui
arrive avec son beat box en dessous de
la fnath a fait appel à lui c'est ce
nous c'est la féécum est un petit peu au
off de toi
le titre est rempli de la nuit avec une
toune qui joue très what the fuck se
regardent pas ta fenêtre c'est le
gutenberg quittés fâchés 95% de chances
que ça marche pas pics à la terrorise
s'apprend pas les odes nautiques soit 11
5% dans un film justement romantique ou
haskell gohari dans bel ami de la nuit
plus kandahar frais de la fille genre
c'est ben beau sauf que mogi des amis
que des gosses en pointe et un milieu de
la nuit cogner dans ma fille harriet
plus d'extinction dont l'ego les choyer
shopping attaque mais c'est ça il ya une
responsabilité des médias aussi
l'attenté autant il ya une
responsabilité collective personnel dans
les cours d'éducation mais aussi
vraiment vraiment vraiment une
responsabilité dans les médias
traditionnels dans les films dans les t
bonds tout ça mais oui effectivement des
boosters 5 fantasque qui dure et qui
dure qui dure depuis toujours qui est à
questionner et yves foncièrement il y
avait et y pense que justement qui avait
été beaucoup partagé ça ramène à ceux ci
c'était juste non veut pas dire qu'on
veuille mois exactement date s'ils
arrêtent de travailler un peu changé
dans les pc cette mesure non plus à
l'humain je voulais qu'on reparle aussi
un petit peu d'air avec toute la
perspective qu'une aux log de là les
différentes les différentes méthodes de
dénonciation parce que le
dans plusieurs de tes plication tu
parles tout de l'aspect légal tu sais tu
traînes un petit peu de l'aspect légal
pileux clairement l'aspect légal un
petit peu pris le bol dans le dernier
mois et puis qu'est-ce qui
qu'est ce qui selon toi qu a choisi nice
et des lacunes au niveau légal
mais quel est selon toi la lecture d'un
mouvement comme celui là mais je veux
dire du haut de mes études le team à ses
étudiants un petit peu de ce que je
comprends comment m'expliquer le système
de justice le présentement et c'est que
c'est vraiment l'idée bon et la
présomption d'innocence qui est
extrêmement forte
heureusement parce que autrement
theillet je pense que notre système de
justice serait un petit peu plus et je
dis tant mieux si je moi je me fais
accuser à tort
raymond la présomption d'innocence me
protège c'est un petit peu moins drôle
en cas d'agression sexuelle parce que
c'est pour que l'agresseur soit reconnu
coupable jusqu'à preuve du contraire
faut qu'il ya un doute raisonnable
puis le fardeau de preuve ceux d'autres
raisonnable il est immense je dis moi je
suis plein de doutes en longueur de
journée et si paul on est de faire en
sorte qu'il ya un doute possible c'est
je pense notamment à quai une victime
une personne victime par exemple qui va
faire un tu vas faire une dénonciation à
la police tout de suite après avoir été
victimisée avoir avoir subi une
victimisation sa mémoire va avoir encore
délais
certains détails demain une manière
peut-être différente de la réalité
c'est normal quand on vit un choc
notre mémoire aj complètement
différemment pourquoi pascal olmeta a
vraiment et focus et sur tout les
détails les plus anodins pour être sûr
qu'elles soient capables de se protéger
ensuite si elle retrouve ses détails
mais des fois ceux ci ça peut être très
tôt si parce que mettons que ce soit
arrivé jeudi un croquis chimie mettons
que ça arrive dans une ruelle
ça se peut que plus tard dans un
contexte état de stress post traumatique
la 8ème et les peurs béret à la che mai
le fait est que ça se peut aussi que de
par la mémoire traumatique qui est un
détail coop qui concordent m'ont dit
qu'ils concordent pas encore peu avec la
première dénonciation et ça ça va être
très utile finalement pour l'avocat de
la défense c'est d'aller jouer sur les
nuances qui ça va pouvoir mettre
peut-être éventuellement un doute
raisonnable tic
donc en ce moment je pense qu est ce qui
est très difficile c'est que c'est la
parole d'une personne contre la parole
d'un autre pilote système de justice
comme il est pensé en ce moment c'est
très difficile d'aller en cours avec
quelque chose comme ça et puis c'est ça
change de plus en plus t on a tendance à
vouloir vraiment été on condamne
beaucoup le système de justice at large
mais il ya des pc pics sont de plus en
plus formés dans les agressions
sexuelles dans l'est en matière
d'agression sexuelle et il ya de plus en
plus de deux dispositifs et des
policiers sont plus formés au site est
bon mais il ya encore énormément de
lacunes selon aussi notamment le poste
de police par lesquels qui tourne
puisque celle ci est encore si ton corps
se poursuit en cours ben c'est l'idée
que des piles la victime et est un
témoin à un peu un peu considéré de
cesser dans le fond c'est l'état qui
poursuit donc la victime est un témoin
donc il veut non seulement peut-être
potentiellement devoir raconter son
histoire donc se replonger dans lisez
tout automatique devant des inconnus
dans un contexte parfois dans un
contexte hyper intimidant puis quelqu'un
qui dans une pitite ici vulnérabiliser
de raconter cette cette victimisation là
tout le temps mais dans un contexte où
on vote on va te remettre en question on
va poser des questions sur le détail de
6,2 soit parce qu'on veut infliger un
doute raisonnable
c'est extrêmement prometteuse en scène
un potentiel de seconde victime d'un
sont encore une ombre devant des
inconnus peut-être devant gérer plus en
plus devant potentiellement ton
agresseurs qui va être dans la salle
devant des témoins finalement qui vont
peut-être ou des amis qui vont peut-être
parler contre toi finalement c'est un
potentiel de victimisation seconde à
immense puits souvent malheureusement ce
qu'on entend c'est que les victimes ont
dit à moi plus jamais tu es tu satisfait
enfin je la ferai pas je veux dire c'est
beaucoup plus marquants ceux comme je
disais en début au début que la
victimisation 1 mt faillite
ce système là aussi qui est extrêmement
difficile pétillant une intervenante du
cavac qui est toujours sur place pour
finalement préparer la victime a
témoigné t il est de plus en plus des
moyens qui sont données pour l'éviter
mais il en demeure pas moins que c'est
extrêmement extrêmement vulnérables y
sentez vraiment beaucoup
puis une fois qu'on sort de de ce
parcours le légal oui mon temps dans des
dénonciations publiques comme le lieu
maintenant est ce que selon toi y
potentiel de glissements ce qui selon
toi y'a potentiel de deux rives et rives
débordement ou où le mouvement va se
réguler par lui même c'est une bonne
question
c'est la question que tout le monde qui
se pose en ce moment c'est parce que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on croit
l'on en croit les dénonciations croit
les victimes et les agresseurs qui sont
encore là demain me dct aux personnes
qui essaient réellement de phare est si
pauvre être soutenu ceux qui acceptent
leurs torts et souffrir avec des excuses
parfois maladroite et qui viennent pas
de la bonne place mais somme toute on
n'a pas vu encore un cas à part
peut-être le françois blanchet qui lui
ni cas des grues nie catégoriquement que
tout se soit arrivé
mais est-ce qu'il ya quand même
potentiel à la dérive
puis si oui comment est ce qu'on y
pallier est-ce qu est-ce que mettons les
cages otis est quoi le masque lattès que
les dommages collatéraux valent la peine
selon moi oui parce que s'il y en a un
parmi mille c'est l'humain ça vaut le
sabot pourcentage
il ya beaucoup de monde aussi qui sont
contre le mouvement qui qui met
l'emphase sur le 1 mais mettons
l'emphase sur le 999 le même c'est plate
pour le riche d'accord c'est pas mal
plate pour l'insight 19 ans mais c'est
ce qui manque
comment est-ce que tu le lis comment est
ce que tu vois ce mouvement là dans son
ensemble un potentiel dérive versus les
potentiels gaming est bâti je pense que
ce mouvement là est né justement du de
l'espèce de d'échec lé de pouvoir
prendre en charge vraiment les besoins
des victimes comme tel dans à travers le
système judiciaire
je pense que le mouvement
essentiellement vise à soulager à
répondre aux besoins finalement de
validation puis ceux ci c'est en ce
moment c'est ce qui arrive c'est
extraordinaire on va d'entrée de jeu on
va croire la victime ça c'est rare que
c'était lui et jusqu'à présent et c'est
tant mieux
puis vraiment si je pense que c'est un
potentiel réparateur et nomme le seul le
simple fait de se faire dire je te crois
tu es réactions sont normales c'est des
réactions normales dans un contexte
normal et je vais t'aider à travers de
soutien n'est que le simple fait de dire
de manière anonyme va être ultra aux
réparateurs puis ça va être la mort
d'une démarche d'un processus de reprise
de pouvoir personnel mais est-il
vraiment tio 1% des dénonciations qui
sont fausses dans un corps dans un
contexte de police de donner en cette
dénonciation pas ça parce que tu
veuilles a pour thème créer une histoire
épique pour vrai aussi des puits souvent
les gens vont fox était justement comme
tu disais là dessus mais écoute pour que
ces allées le verbaliser bien c'est
tellement dommageable de passer à
travers tout ce que tu veux tu peux
faire c'est juste pour le fun c'est ou
juste pour parvis et par vengeance sur
quelqu'un c'est extrêmement
c'est vraiment vraiment et pense que ce
1% là s'applique aux mouvements
princesse et surtout quand les
négociations sont à même exactement
c'était la manu ans où je m'en venais
c'est que c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'ailleurs ton ordinateur
et demain puis je pense notamment la
liste de noms ou pas d'explication il ya
pas des pigeons dire des jeux dit
n'importe quoi mais des gens tremblé
dans au québec
il s'élance enfin le où j'ai moi j'ai
une certaine diagonale c'est que je me
disais que c'est facile de fascinant
guillemets de partir de thons de ton
ordinateur qui de vouloir te venger pour
x y z raison au goût de vous payer
quelque chose août puis je pense qu'il
ya une éducation profonde à faire sur la
différence entre c'est quoi une
inconduite à caractère sexuel puis une
agression sexuelle
je pense aux faits notamment de se faire
sexuée sexuée temps quatre cols cystine
inconduite
puis après bon le symbole jusqu'à plus
large preuves de l'agression sexuelle
avec pénétration en nombre mais oui tu
es je pense qu'un certain risque d'être
de plus en plus tu es aussi surtout
quand il ya juste des noms tels il faut
quand même avoir une certaine avoir un
commencerait bien s'est-il ce qui est
arrivé c'est qu'il ya eu des
dénonciations les gens se sont excusés
ils ont quand même reconnu d'une
certaine dans la mesure de ce qui
pouvait être capables de reconnaître et
ont quand même reconnu qu'il y avait eu
des problèmes dans les comportements
problématiques toxiques à caractère
sexuel mail avec la liste de noms je
pense que ça peut mener éventuellement
aussi incertaine dérape
mais je peux prête à condamner le
mouvement complet accord exact exact
mais moi moi justement
je trouve que deux aspects le pied
mettons une dénonciation comme sa fille
andrée le fait c'est de mettre ton nom
de mettre ton visage de décrire des
événements puis moi j'ai autant le
mouvement positif en ce moment autant
jeu je peux capable de me dire que la
façon de le faire c'est une liste
anonyme avec aucun concert avec bouquin
contexte je peux pas je peux pas dire tu
es maintenant la liste je pense que
c'était sûr sur facebook une page
facebook qui a sorti une liste il y
avait à peu près 1000 noms là dessus
avec aucune distinction entre les noms
autant je suis persuadé que dans cette
liste lol y'a un très très haut
pourcentage de personnes que c'est des
agresseurs mais je ne peux pas dire que
c'est la façon de faire je peux pas
endosser ce pas ce qu'il ya comme tu dis
un cadre calme puis une agression
sexuelle mais ton force et une
pénétration par exemple c'est tellement
loin
c'est tellement loin oui c'est des
agressions oui c'est une agression mais
c'est tellement loin il y en a un qu'il
faut que tu dises doute fait possible
puis un autre vous qui le met en prison
a ses limites
c'est effectivement que c'est là encore
une fois t'es jamais mon chapeau mon
pays je médite et après on peut pas
juger de la réaction d'une personne qui
me fait 4 calme ouais c'est jeudi de cap
et on les voit qu'une pénétration non
désirée ou plutôt donc exactement mais
il ya quand même le mater a étudié comme
il faut qu est ce qui est arrivé qui
donnait finalement c'est comme voir le
contexte pour pouvoir être à même d'en
juger puis de tirs aux cubains se sait
ça arrive je veux le savoir le
reconnaître
la liste majine profonde des chinois
mais qui paie mais mais mais je
comprends ta réticence à dire exactement
tait parce que c'est tellement quelque
chose qui ait d'autres chez moi - métier
je veux partir avec la prémisse que je
suis pour à 100 % ce qui se passe en ce
moment tu et ceci même pas à mettre sur
la table chez sap ensemble
oui maintenant c'est tout est dans la
manière tout est dans la manière
les vrais comprendront mais si ça fait
je trouve que pipi c'est une des choses
aussi que tu soulèves bien candide
analyse la réponse de julien lacroix ou
est-ce qui dit on on pose beaucoup de
questions sur qu'est-ce qui est la face
on le fait en ce moment c'est même toit
le s'est passé avec toile c'est un
dossier très exhaustif et on vient pas
mal non et pourtant même panique
évidemment un nom qui pops une liste
d'au moins 100 contexte lente oci
il ya un travail de journaliste qui
était en haïti pourrait m'en doute là
dessus mais tipi a que des victimes si
je comprends tellement aussi pourquoi tu
voudrais rester anonyme si oui pourquoi
tu voudrais pas vit à damas se dit
pourquoi tu voudrais quand même qu aimer
ton site et agresser les gens sachent à
qui cette personne ne fait attention ce
qu'on le comprend tellement même du
point de vue de l'agresseur s'est dit on
à tous nous on était méchant tu gagnes
avoir réfléchi sur nos propres
comportements mais sait-on depuis je
parle des filles du fils me disent la
même chose c'est me mets ton moi j'ai
pensé à mon passé mes pensées mes
expériences midi puis bon je vois pas
omettant de deir emar problématique
je pense pas mais se mettront mon nom
apparaît sur la liste
c'est difficile d'avoir le processus de
reconnaissance dans le processus de
d'antan mais un changement quelconque
quand c'est pau c'est quoi qui étaient
reprochés
exactement c 'est et député du pan sinon
un point essentiel c'est que pour pierre
et habitation pour quelle reconnaissance
du problème faut d'abord avoir accès à
s'exciter kwal le problème utilité quoi
l'événement problématique des puits sur
la liste je pense que ça permet pour ça
donc c'est vraiment plus ce qu'est ce
c'est l'idée de penser là où ça pourrait
déraper
c'est dans cette zone bleue puis si on
parlait de perception tantôt je te
montrer certains actes anodins pour un
voire traumatique qui est pour un autre
kit est dans un cas soit soient
judiciaires ou même outil ou monde dans
le comté de danse à sion où finalement
les juges simple nous tous si ce kit à
chelsea c'est qu'il ya des dénonciations
les témoignages c'est à nous de décider
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que ces gens le
sait quoi leur peine c'est quoi le pitch
mais est-ce qu'on doit
qu'est ce qui doit être pris en compte
justement la perception du truc cool une
espèce d'objectivité de de ce qui lui
arrivait comment est ce que je faisais
ouais mais tu étais par rapport à la can
sur la culture un peu de tout ce qui se
passe ou par rapport à béton mais tombe
je fais quelque chose que c'est souvent
si j'ai l'impression que des fois il est
tellement une distorsion des perceptions
entre l'agresseur et la victime que pour
eux c'est pas grave piller voyons dans
de l'autre côté c'est ultramatic ti qui
mettons en tant que juge et jury de tss
comment est-ce qu'on l'interprète de ce
qu'on est
est-ce qu'on l'interprète de la
perception de la victime où est-ce qu'on
attend un essai de prendre cette façon
objective c est ce que l'agression est
ce qui la lie l'agression est aussi
sévère au point ty et gala comment la
victime se sent ou vraiment où l'acte
reproché comme tel comme ce que je
faisais ouais mais dans le fond tu es
moi j'ai tendance à dire qu'il peut
importe le la victimisation comme tel
les réactions sont peuvent être
différentes et non le petit coup je sais
pas moi quelqu'un quelqu'un a un passé
traumatique donc quelqu'un a été par
exemple agressée sexuellement dans
l'enfance puisqu'elle est ce fait pogner
une fesse dans un bord de manière très
très très existantes ça se noie réactive
des [ __ ] les émotions des petites de
stress post traumatique donc je pense
que c'est
c'est vraiment une nuance à faire
souvent tendance à des foyers rachid il
est bon les en fait fuchs qu'il faut que
je dis c'est qu'il faut pour
hiérarchiser les réactions et plutôt que
mes william hiérarchisation des ptt
comportement le haut 6e che c'est quand
il ya prépondérance de témoignages le
tient en ce moment comme je pense a dit
lacroix qui est fait oui il ya
prépondérance et oui c'est difficile de
ne pas condamner de dire bello et puis
on a quand même et en tant que société
on
on a un certain petit on a un besoin de
justice et puis des fois quand je sais
c'est pas fait mais là ça se transforme
en besoin de vengeance et où un besoin
d'eux comme de dire mais regarde toi tu
mérite pas ce mérite pas la place qui te
pisse et la manière dont on veut
collectivement s'unir pour que si pour
que tu sois finalement et cancel et en
bon anglais mais j'ai une question qui
peut sembler dur mais je peux qu'elle
soit mal et après tri mais est-ce que ce
que tim est en dit déjà qu'ils vont lire
des témoignages font dire voyant dans ce
prix une agression mais est ce que est
ce que tu m'as manqué une personne se
sent agressé il ya une agression haute
au point de vue criminels non c'est à
dire que je vais dire non mais je sous
toute réserve
si jamais il s'y est jamais des gens qui
nous écoutent qu'ils aient oui oui ça va
me faire plaisir de
mais était effectivement tu es je pense
qu'il ya matière criminelle il ya
vraiment des balises à respecter en
terme de destination et qui peut être
poursuivi au criminel mais en tant que
ceux-ci oui je pense que c'est
importante et est à l'écouté
la réaction cette réaction est vrai
illustre exactement exactement pis mais
après la conséquence c'est moi je pense
que ce qu'est ce qu'on oublie beaucoup
dans laquelle sort culture justement ce
jeu tellement dur à dire cinq adjoints
seront pas trop mais on oublie aussi le
contexte de réhabilitation mais c'est
sûr que si je sais ce que je dis un peu
en début de 2e d'indiction c'est que
pour qui la réhabilitation totale et il
faut qu'ils aient un certain système de
soutien autorités jeudi pas de vivre la
compassion se dit peut-être complètement
du côté de l'agresseur vraiment pas mais
je pense que quand même c'est moi je
rêve du moment où une entreprise veut
dire à qui on se dit ceci pour l'instant
de cette personne là mais on va on va
s'assurer avec elle qu'elle ait les
moyens pour aller chercher de l'aide
technique quand elle fera son chemin
mais peut-être le con con con on
repensera notre contre eux avec je peux
c'est clair ce que je dis mais j'ai hâte
au moment où comme si c'est normal qu'on
veuille cancellé cette personne-là sept
personnes et a causé du tort qu'ils
soient et objectifs et subjectifs août
et il ya eu tort causé c'est normal
qu'on dise moi je veux plus rien savoir
de cette personne ne retient on fait
impressionnant nos vielles aussi des
fois certains degrés c'est normal puis
je pense que ces deux valides énormément
les émotions de la victime que de faire
nous on y est on a eu la version des
faits comme on veut plus en entendre
parler va prendre soin de toi puis mais
je pense qu'il ya quand même une
discussion tranquillement avoir sur les
chances de réhabilitation
parce que pour qui les chances de
réhabilitation piteux prise de
conscience du problème mais faut qu'un
espoir et fauqué faut que la personne
elle a un espoir de vivre une vie quand
même somme toute équilibrée et fac lui
si on l'a quand celle ci était c'est sûr
que ça amoindri beaucoup c'était 7,7 et
sports l'ex et 6 et puis d'espoir si
plus aucun espoir on va se retrouver
avec avec des gens qui s'enlève la vie
le cap des 700 ce petit jeu c'est
personne veut seul humain fakty oui
c'est bon tu sais si je comprends la
réaction je suis la première à faire
avec cette personne moi je la d'élite
par toutes les teintes un truc est
normal aussi qui est instinctif presque
qu'ils puissent ionel mai mais cette
vague de dénonciations là aussi j'ai
hâte qu'elle se transforme sans
discussion plus large sur les chances de
réhabilitation autant pour la victime
parce que parce que travailler un
contexte dramatique c'est aussi de la
réhabilitation c'est un droit commun
vivre comment ne pas être défini par son
traumatisme comme en est au même titre
qu'un criminel ça va être comment ne pas
être défini comme on a pu être définie
par son passé criminel mars et par ses
actes
donc c'est maintenant tous les temps et
du coup c'est une vraie une
réhabilitation avec des angles
différents de dette approche mais gégé
haute qu'on parle un peu de ce contexte
sûr que c'est encore fragile parce qu'on
est encore en train de s'informer et de
digérer d'accord la shopping ou liés
c'est beaucoup d'émotion et puis qu'il
veut pas de menace c'est raide et le
canada d'en parler parce que mais par
rapport à justement le fait qu'un
célèbre le fait de vouloir couper
certaines personnes de leur vie beaucoup
d'ajustements qui vont qu'est-ce qui le
mouvement 10 à sa pub en scène de quelqu
un va tout perdre pour ce très pipi
c'est aussi quelque chose que monsieur
lacroix d'enfants
travail du bic et que je perds à côté de
quelque chose comme ce métier je pense
pas et je pense que si vraiment il ya un
processus qui est fait la personne c'est
sûr qu'à beau perdre des choses c'est
sûr qu'ils vont devoir prendre du recul
pendant certaines périodes mais très
moche quand même convaincu mes repères
morin ont un peu fini de la voix mais
non on va la revoir à voir venir à vous
dire je suis en thérapie c'est vrai que
j'avais des comportements complètement
déplacé dans le passé en plus de ce que
j'ai construit mon sujet j'ai changé si
je reconnais mes torts puis à bâle à
tout le monde en parle a beau dire ce
qu'ils ont on va dire ben on donne une
chance à présent que ce qui va bien oui
pions on y reconnaît petit c'est des
gens qui somme toute sont talentueux et
l'accès ou excuse moi non mais c'est ça
parce que c'est juste qu'après ce c'est
très difficile de savoir si une personne
et il y en a un client qu'on avait les
visions type c'est que savoir sortir
rapidement le tient maintenant la
tolérance pour les hamburgers va être
vraiment à son plus petit et c'est ça
qui est ça veut savoir si rapidement
messi est un être là dedans psy vraiment
chamakh effet puissant ennemi changement
guérison de vue commente après ce bain
sa vie sa carrière et pas de terminer
moutier ben non c'est si j'ose espérer
que c'est comme un départ à 0 tc comme
un peu comme quand quelqu'un est arrêté
qui s'en va en prison mais il par tous
et il part tout comme un petit plus je
veux pas content si je veux pas comparer
ces à la prison à ce qui vit en ce
moment si tu peux vraiment pas la
pulsion mai
il en demeure pas moins qu'ils perdront
leur contrat ils perdent bon tour des
l'arrimage est haché banque ccc mais le
fait est que j'espère que quand ils vont
venir ce sera pas y reviendrons pas sur
un niveau n'est pas ce que c'est des
gens qui sont foncièrement qui vont se
baser sur leur talent et non sur le
pouvoir et non celui de l'espèce de
règne de silence qui se fait puis
j'espère vraiment qu'ils vont avoir pris
le temps qu'un petit d'avoir fait
l'examen sincère qu'il était marche
profonde pour revenir on l'a vu un petit
peu avec joël legendre
comme si c'était que c'était un petit
c'est autre chose mais il ya eu sans une
certaine sympathie ou en tout cas n'en
pâtit plus tôt par rapport à sa démarche
je vois que les gens ont aussi on est
capable quand même de dégrader les
offenses le dans ce sens que joël
legendre
ce qui est fait c'est par rapport à
d'autres qui sont sortis dans les mêmes
périodes maintenant on va voir le pardon
moins facile pour d'autres quels projets
de l'agent même chose qui est pour mais
ton tu es encore une fois si on prenait
demain exemple marie pierre puis julien
par exemple quand même marge une région
je suis vraiment jugement
d'accord mais une autre question qui
vient c'est y est justement dans la
gradation dans l'éventail des dessins
conduite sexuelle
c'est comme à partir de où ça mérite
d'être qualité seacom qui sont qui va
répondre justement à cause que les
réactions sont très variables
dépendamment oui des enfants ce métier
ya dix ans je disais je pense pas que
beaucoup de gens qui ont ils des
témoignages qu'on disait qu'ils sont à
glacer le syndic sanctions comme les
masses et des personnes
sociable qui quittent et violeur en
série c'est ce type i des témoignages à
répétition sur des témoignages petite
bombe était cette personne le dieu merci
que ça soit sorti parce que je savais
aucun bon sentier qui puis d'autre que
le temps parle de mon autour de top six
mois mais andré cet artiste cologne
factice est sûre c'est à partir de
whoopi le surtout en ce moment j'ai
l'impression que le mouvement se
transforme typique on parle pas
seulement des agressions sexuelles par
les coupables de comportements taxé de
violence psychologique qui je voyais
voyant une publication qui disent qu'on
a tous été taxé ce ses soucis on sait
tous déjà chicaner sur des trucs qu'on
n'a pas laissé aller qu'on aurait dû on
a tous été un peu chiant sur certaines
affaires tpiy pilote audio aac etc
c'est qu'est ce qui est une mauvaise
expérience avec un individu qui est ce
qui vraiment comportement toxiques qui
me qui mérite d'être adressé en public
le gsee
est-ce que c'est d'intérêt public sur
cette question le aussi tu tentes autant
tous deux toujours pas dans mes
expériences puis je vois pas je pourrais
être dans ce sens qu il ya près de casio
où j'étais et toxiques et irrespectueux
rémy je pense que un être humain
irréprochable visiter ce justement
j'avais partagé quelqu'un pose là dessus
c'est en parlant de monsieur blanchet tu
le sais qu'il s'agit toujours huawei
toujours été irréprochable avec les
femmes oui vraiment
permets-moi d'ordinateurs ce que je te
garantis que moi nom que lui non c'est
que nos gars c't'un gars n'ont jamais ou
une personne que jamais qu'elle était
irréprochable jamais jamais il des
limites à jouer surtout quand tu étais
imprésario d'éric lapointe besoin laisse
moi à quel point avec une femme pacsée
se mêlent donc après ça ça chanceux je
pense pas que tu oublies tout le monde
mérite d'être quand les français
notamment qui tend à tort je la mets à
parler de ce soir à vouloir avoir l'air
de quelqu'un qui dans la peau leurs yeux
dalmau des cas non non non mais il ya
certaines choses que je me dis on va
montrer que c'est plus des gens c'est
plus une chicane dont je suis témoin
sujets témoins du scan en public plutôt
que mal eux
l'essence du texte cuse les agresseurs
météo on se comprend puisque en plus en
plus loin de l'essence du truc au début
qui tu es tellement nécessaire ouais
mais ce que ça fait je pensais qu'ils
étaient tout à fait d'accord avec toi
puis dit on parlait justement d'aider
rappelé je pense que c'est une autre
avenue aussi où il ya matière à se
questionner vraiment des ce que si vous
mentir parce que c'est d'intérêt public
ou non - il ya une coupe de trucs qui
sont sortis récemment que j'ai commencé
comme ça me regarde pas c'est dans son
soutien et puis j'ai des rejets si on
était témoin comme tu le dit d'une
espèce de chicane surtout quand c'est
une personne à une autre
il ya prépondérance le j'ai très mal ces
étudiants qui n'ont c'est vraiment une
culture triste ou des personnes en
position de pouvoir et qu'il puisera ses
succès montre exactement métier c'est
sûr qu'il ya de plus en plus de coparent
que c'est bien délicate en ce moment
d'aller dans ces zones là mais le fait
tic wild ça ça ouvre la porte à la fois
où j'étais allé en 2017 at-elle place
puis c'est correct mais mais il ya
peut-être matière à ce questionnaire
savoir tirer en ce moment tout tout tout
tout seul puis c'est tant mieux mais je
pense qu'on va pouvoir une fois que tout
va être sorti ou en tout cas une fois
que contre comprennent complètement que
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais c'est
pas ça va être d'aller plutôt parler de
voir en privé avec la personne c'est
quelqu'un qui commet est réceptive ou
non plus si la personne a trois victimes
depuis que si puisque seul le style
monte à faire aussi mais effectivement
le lieu de plus en plus des nuances qui
font en sorte que mais ça ça ça déplace
le débat financier puis que ça fait en
sorte qu'ils puissent justement ces gens
parlent à une amie aussi je me disais
moi j'ai peur sur une base personnelle
que ça que ça ça décrédibilise les
victimes parce que
c'est ça le danger si tout le monde est
une victime plus tôt montrent un
agresseur sa belle et bum le bébé
personnes vivant en france non plus
et puis effectivement 6 si la tendance
se maintient que ça continue à devenir
de plus en plus vague et les chants de
dénonciation effectivement que ça va
l'argument principal pour n'importe qui
qui se fait qu'au real puis c'est juste
juste mettons pour revenir à la liste
anonyme ça à mon avis un argument tout
et même nous qui sont pour le mouvement
on dit ouah c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure façon fait que c'est la plume
un ultime pour quelqu'un qui la tue qui
veut discréditer le truc laitiers fait
que c'est comme les d'érable sont
dangereuses pour le mouvement s'est
allumé à tout le monde individuellement
mais une autre affaire que je voulais
qu'on contre est juste que par rapport à
cela parce que avant qu'en pense juste
que tu viens de dire si j'ai vu des
méthodes et des femmes impliquées dans
le mouvement anti d'aidé que victime
justement de probablement de faux
témoignages des gens qui veulent les
crédibiliser le mouvement qui utilisent
ces phares qui te laisser faiblesse
justement l'anonymat puisque pour jouer
justement au propre jeu du truc puis
qu'ici c'est dommage parce que justement
plusieurs gens qui en profitent du fait
que ces sorties qui s'est pas certain à
100% que ça ne m
justement ça c'est assez rare tout - et
moins seuls et ils le on peut on va
commencer à voir des vraiment des faux
témoins qui disent c'est simplement pour
ça que je pense que c'est une bonne
affaire que le on sent quand même un
ralentissement pied du mouvement je
pense que le symbole est fort à ce
moment ci probablement qu'ils étaient il
ya plein de victimes qui ont pas
témoigner parce qu'il sentait pas prêt
tout il voulait pas le faire ici tout à
fait leur droit
de fait une belle publication sur
seulement lundi les victimes ont le
droit de le faire
si vous voulez pas témoigné sous ben
c'est pas correct ça reviendra d'une
agence avec l'éclectique mais j'ai le
feeling que l'on va aller voir une
discussion comme tu parlais tout à
l'heure une section un peu plus large
je pense que là on a probablement fait
le tour des dénonciations anonymes
cg le filet ce que j'espère c'est qu'on
veut s'en inspirer encore une fois dans
les cours d'éducation sexuelle entre
qu'est ce qu'un comportement toxiques qu
est ce qu un système dynamique de
violences conjugales qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est une inconduite
sexuelle qu'est-ce qui est une agression
sexuelle qu'est ce qu'ils étaient
pourquoi on n'utilise plus le mot viol
plutôt que puis qu'on préfère
l'agression sexuelle dont toutes ces ses
comptes c'est vraiment ces sujets là qui
finalement qu'ils sont petits peut
l'atteindre à travers la ville la
dénonce le système de dénonciation
actuelle je pense que j'espère qu'on
pense que j'espère qu'on veut s'en
inspirer pour vraiment comme aller poser
des questions de fond piqué ont séduit
je pense aussi que c'est si ça ou la
discussion justement va le dire puisque
l'egypte il faut en parler aussi c'est
un autre fléau ccnb de savoie au citer
qu'eux mais que tu peut plus agir en
toute impunité se situe si c'est positif
peu plus juste
agresser ou jeu sept violeurs petit tube
qui pensaient que ça te retrouveras
jamais cela je pense que beaucoup de
gens qui dorment sur wake up call qui
s'est passé c'est une des choses que je
suis plus contenté de citer ce mouvement
reste le média qui tu sais tu peut plus
agir en toute impunité et ils ont ces
chèques mais même même se tut tut après
l'histoire de parce que il ya plusieurs
personnes qui ont parlé par rapport à
marie permet même si c'est un conduite
sur des plateaux de tournage primes
demandées dans des concepts dans des
contextes de travail
puis il y avait 1-1 des témoignages 10e
mais je réalisais je comprenais pas
comment la chine même genre deux mois
après que toute sortie sur salvat est le
tien comme je comprends pas comment
quelqu'un peut continuer à agir comme ça
quand tu sais que ça peut servir et
qu'on doit maintenant que tu es con
pouvoir te rends pas intouchable du
puits puis c'est ceci aussi au moins
maintenant à guez qui en a qui vont
continuer mais au moins je me dis que la
majorité grand pourcentage vont réaliser
comme tu dis que sont pas intouchables
c'est ce que je voulais dire tantôt
c'est que toi qui viens d'un milieu
artistique
c'est une question que j'ai extrêmement
difficultés imposées
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec l'or de daga
sont leur passé fait que m l'exemple est
on
woody allen tout est sorti sur lui
qu'elle est pas mal quand celle est
partout ouais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
les films de woody allen
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les special
stand-up de louis siquet qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec tes qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
les vidéos devient la croix qui sont
faux king drôle encore ti qui m'ont
encore vraiment beaucoup rire qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec lors de ces gens là moi
je moi de répondre à cette question
parce que peut-être une réflexion qui va
faire avancer la mienne merci déjà posé
cette question là parce que même moi je
lâche la commencer - moi j'suis super
temps déséquilibres et des fois je me
disais qu'ils ont pensé le tout
des fois je me dise qu'on sépare la
personne de ses agissements en même
temps et c'est je pense à michael
jackson moi je peux plus et que michael
jackson s'est terminée je suis parce que
je change les coudes quand je l'entends
je vois juste tout ce sur quoi ça repose
c'est tout est pourtant ça enlève rien à
son talent mais j'ai une association qui
que je peux plus m'en vais de la tête
mais sainté c'est vraiment une question
qui mérite d'être posée
ça m'est revenue une en face l'autre
pour les temps changent ensemble puisque
comme deux jours après la fin de kevin
parent du genre sont témoins son excuse
à l'udc de bâle à moi je m'en vais puis
sont les bols qui se dope son âge à qui
le drop
là on est dans le champ à 100 mon écoute
une station radio brendon sur la morale
puis c'est une tonne de carbone par ap
le de fait auquel on est deux jours plus
tard que subit mais sans que ça prend un
certain temps avant que je rejoue donc
moi je dirigeais oui mais fait que je
pense qu'un truc de délai l'attend au
site et d'éviter aussi que bon être est
ce que vraiment d'attendre justement que
la personne par elles mêmes reviennent
aussi le petit peu plus ses métiers dans
les cotes vous dit aline de michael
jackson tout ce système mais j'attendrai
peut-être justement de voir c'est quoi
la démarche personnelle la personne
c'est quoi ces gestes concrets qu'elle a
fait pour reconnaître mais aller de
l'avant pis depuis perpétuer ces
comportements le pi peut-être que
lorsqu'on est ce serait plus facile de
s'approprier l'oeuvre la personne en
connaissance de cause mais que quand
même continuer et d'écouter et
d'entendre finalement autre chose qu est
ce que la personne à petit en terme de
réhabilitation michael jackson ne peut
terminer mais tu vois tu sais pas c'est
une question qu'on répondra jamais ça
collectivement moins on parlera jamais
une décision que lexus au québec tels
artistes on le voit plus petit ou pis ça
vient chacun sa deviens moi je me pose
beaucoup cette question loupé ça devient
c'est même peu rationnel c'est émotif
c'est comment je me sens juste à manger
comme toi michael jackson je pinaille
écoutez je pense qu'à peine 1 écoutez je
serai à l'écouté beaucoup voient ça me
joue et où j'ai joué j'ai fait mon
métier l'aide à jouer dans les bars qui
change
j'en fais plus cupides en fait partie je
fais mon métier
woody allen ça fait des années qu'ils se
termine mais as préféré jean louis mahé
moustique d'or cfmci je trouve que c'est
un génie
sauf que j'étais c'était pas capable
d'apprécier l'oeuvre parce que tu es
juste penser à se serrer mon expérience
de l'oeuvre de la réponse à ta question
moi mais en même temps c'est un peu on
dirait que c'est un pelage de consommer
l'oeuvre en essayant en y pensant pas
activement à cette question la caisse et
mettons pas si j'écoute un film de woody
allen 10 facile facile le mettre devant
match mais juste écouter match facile
pour toi
non mais c'est facile pour moi mais je
trouve ça l'âge de 2 juste parce que je
trouve que jean ya une réflexion qu'il
faut que je fasse que je me dois de
faire que si c'est juste mettre les
limites le film il écoute et je fais pas
cette réflexion là qui est nécessaire
mais si tu la fais péter capable de
cannes passer par-dessus d'apprécier
leur soumettons louis sic et moi
personnellement je compte encore capable
d'éduquer ses enfants pu trouver ça
drôle sa peau
je sais de faire l'examen personnel de
commenter nous en ce sens par rapport à
ça c'est koi no limit c'est quoi tes
parce que moi je dirais même temps m bon
je viens là quoi j'ai écouté son sens
assez riche et simple projet 2000 c'est
sûr que et puis je l'apprécié beaucoup
julien lacroix j'apprécie beaucoup son
humour sa présence est tout je me vois
mal être capable d'apprécier je dirais
que ça serait plus qu'une réflexion ce
serait je suis venu présenter sa tâche
mais finalement mon plaisir de l'écouté
mais c'est sûr que c'est des films comme
oudéa l'une des fois je reste simple
mais je vais l'écouter quand même et je
vais quand même essayer d'avoir une
réflexion 5,5 mais c'est tout y passe
des fois je me dirais qu'ils n'ont à
qu'est ce tu fais le tu encourages kéba
cissé la base c'est l'autre point
nautisme moindre match choc et ports où
il ya de l'argent qui va personnes le
plus serré sans aussi le plus fou le
juger avec nos yeux aujourd'hui dans sa
requête je continue de lire platon même
si socrate coucher des tilleuls six ans
qui pays et les banquettes platon c'est
sur le sillon des petits gains pillés
ont fait on se laisse aller trimer mais
le ce ne sont pas des ddc l'autre tant
d'autres mrc indiqué patrick est faux
pas n'a pas relancé ce mes
mais le sait c'est plus serré sans plus
puis je pense qu'il faut le juger tu
évolues dans le même dans la même
société qu'ils avaient des comportements
décalé par rapport à nos normes à nous
la caisse que servier pour toi c'est
quoi les les projets sur lesquels je
travaille qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la
rentrée scolaire et je retourne à
l'école et à la maison les incrimine au
donc dans le frimas de cours à finir en
victimologie
c'est super beau coup en plus mais puis
je vais axer le tranquillement mis mes
recherches va vraiment moi je veux
travailler essentiellement dans auprès
des des victimes deux hommes
j'aimerais de plus en plus explorée
finalement les avenues par rapport à
tout ça parce que peut il ya vraiment
peu des deux il ya d'écrit face à
montréal mais il ya peu d'accent donné
aux hommes qui sont victimes
d'agressions sexuelles autant par des
hommes que par les femmes
ça arrive mais on ne doit pas parler
exactement parce que les sommes pas des
hommes j'en doute paumé mais une victime
sommes des gros sexuel par une femme
je le connais de sa patrie mais mettons
on étudie chiffres on n'a pas de
chiffres
pourquoi parce qu'il est un homme qui va
dénoncer son agresseur femme va se faire
rire socialement parce qu'il soit il va
se farder tu avais juste défendre soi va
se faire dire ici par agression sexuelle
j'entends pas juste pénétration payer
tout on le fait qu'ils peuvent se faire
que dans un camp un contexte agression
sexuelle c'est souvent on a tendance à
dire mais oui mais et il y avait je sape
au bond et épices et puis après on peut
pas non plus contrôler les réactions
physiologiques ont aussi mai
mais la dénonciation est extrêmement
difficile puis le fait de reconnaître
qu'il ya eu agression sexuelle ou c'est
extrêmement difficile pour plein de
raisons
oui mais j'étais je devrais je devrais
le vouloir je voudrais je devrais
vouloir ça avons une relation sexuelle
avec sa fille il attise en dépit du
refus j'extrapole avec la culture du
viol métier déserté les goûts je
souhaite c'est utile je fais des gros
godillots steria est petit mais il ya
énormément de stigma autour de
l'agression sexuelle surtout d'une femme
envers un homme la violence conjugale
même chose s'est il ya énormément de
violences conjugales d'une femme envers
un homme c'est juste qu'on en entend peu
parler parce qu'elle est difficile à
reconnaître parce qu il s est positionné
un peu plus dans la violence
psychologique émotionnel économique
spirituel mai puis un petit peu moins
physique tu es et fac c'est dur pour un
homme de dire date d'arrivée puis dire
mais moi je dénonce mon agresseur
il va avoir toutes sortes si pour les
filles c'est difficile il va voir si peu
pour mettre encore plus d'empathie sur
les hommes mais pas en terme de
victimologie comme tel les hommes vont
se faire vraiment vraiment vraiment que
me rentrer dedans par plusieurs
intervenants au cours de leurs processus
d'aidé non violent même le gars qui
avait le musicien qui avait témoigné
pour marie pierre morin dans le fond
c'est lui d'élite et sa publication a
pris parce que c'était si je suis
vraiment si par jean bernard moraine
french ta gueule et c'est jean le cam à
nice et comme une agression mais ici se
fait abuser après dark amateurs parce
que belle-fille exactement fait que donc
voilà je vais essentiellement concentrée
levier mes coureurs
aller dans cette direction le jean et
j'aimerais essentiellement ses phares
une maîtrise donc c'est pas mal ça je
pense que c'est logique si j'ai ma
plateforme qui est en train de changer
énormément et donc j'ai tellement active
j'adore cet us comme dans un état de
flou en ce moment là si j'ai pas mangé
pendant une semaine ce qui est une bonne
chose et que je vais faire cette affaire
c'est la farce et puis parce que je veux
prendre le moment pendant qu'on écoute
parce que j'ai fait une publication sur
les billets les préjugés les plus
communs dans ce qu'ils vont faire en
sorte que la culture du vieux se permet
depuis une semaine avant que tout ça
éclate
si j'avais eu des partis moi c'est mon
combat quotidien et de tout petit je
veux dire j'arrive chez nous que
j'écoute avec sting genre en boucle même
si je viens de faire six heures de
victimes autres sinon je suis là dans
tout le temps éventuellement j'aurai à
apprendre amoureux meilleur équilibre de
vie
mais ça me passe un ferme en pis j'ai
mis cette publication là donc pillent eu
un impact moindre parce que j'ai eu une
centaine de jeunes en une heure je les
ai remis pendant la semaine où il y
avait l'essentiel des dénonciations
s'étaient partagés 2000 3000 fois
faculté c'est je pense que les gens
écoutent fois que j'essaye d'apprendre
tout en gardant une certaine santé
mentale mais oui j'aime si j'aime cet
actif qui j'aime se voir que ça fait une
différence c'est mimi mais les
publications gilles privilège d'avant ce
dialogue là j'ai le privilège d'avoir
cette tribune le mais je vais l'utiliser
à bon escient mais moi c'est comme ça
que j'ai découvert aussi justement
durant la vague je voyais des gens
justement partagé t pause puis
d'éducation qui sont extrêmement
pertinentes sont extrêmement pleine
d'informations on était vraiment de
rigueur aussi si l'on veut dire on sent
vraiment la rigueur puis la recherche
mais c'est ce qui ce qui est intéressant
puis
c'est bien aussi des fois de lire des
contes parce que c'est pas juste
men's trash oui toujours ma nature h
sans arrêt ça c'est comme ce qu elle
aussi d'être capable saccadé geek un
petit peu autour de ces choses là
c'est important que c'est des fois
j'essaie de j'essaie d'avoir vraiment de
donner des contextes et des concepts qui
devrait être reconnu tu es comme la
seconde utilisation ou l'arrêt
victimisation qu'on devrait comprendre
pour être à même de comprendre un peu
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment
aussi
mais des fois je me permets une opinion
c'est une certaine perspective nous
débattons en 30 secondes la différence
entre victimisation pire en 30 secondes
chrono
et dans le fond la victimisation
secondaire qui est aussi la seconde
victime d'associations anem
c'est l'idée justement que tu veux
dénoncer que tu vas te faire remettre en
question finalement la viabilité de t2
du tramway comme tel et dudu de tes
réactions traumatique dansant sous as
pas si grave dans toutes ses réponses le
porter quoi
c'est en tout je disais c'est dans un de
mes tontons thiam ça devrait être
correct et bon surtout toutes ces
réactions là qu'ils vont finir qui vont
invalides et finalement la personne
victime qui vont faire en sorte que ça
va être ça va complexifier la demande a
été finalement parce que plusieurs
victimisation puis cristallisation des
symptômes aussi et pour la victimisation
plier victimisation secondaire puis
cristallisation des symptômes de stress
post traumatique puis l'arrêt
victimisation c'est l'idée d'être
victime faisait donc de vivre une note
victimisation par quelqu'un d'autre
donc d'être mettons de vécu de vivre
deux agressions sexuelles par deux
agresseurs
parce que je suis content nous poser des
questions et moi même si on est à dix
points contre lui mais est ce que le
fait d'allaiter victimiser finalement
été victimes d'agressions a compté
chances de victimes faisaient de relever
la victimisation
oui pourquoi parce que ça c'est ce qu'on
a appris rapidement leur avis que mal
agi
c'est qu'il ya des facteurs de
vulnérabilité qui viennent avec eux avec
une agression on parle peu et je pense
c'est notamment et au fait que je vais
te donner un exemple rouge général
intense la petite fille s'est fait
agresser dans l'enfance par quelqu'un le
vieux qui on va dire une adolescente qui
s'est faite agressée sexuellement par et
par un homme elle une baisse à la des
réactions traumatique qui sont pas
adressés nécessairement parce que une
personne victime est obligé de dénoncer
rapidement non plus si certains noms
truc qu'on compte souvent tellement de
raison pourquoi il suffit qu'une
personne pourrait prendre du temps
et puis cette personne le bond est moins
motivée au moins confiance et une
rupture du lien de confiance dans
l'humanité donc à moins confiance et
plus renfermé va avoir maintenant une
perte de motivation l'école va décider
je sais pas moi ne pas poursuivre ses
études
pile se retrouver dans un contexte où
bon je sais pas le poids de soutien
informel ou formelles donc moins de
soutien amical tous vos ce matin par
exemple le jeu mais ce rôle c'est
beaucoup c'est va se mettre à consommer
pour pallier finalement aux états de
stress post traumatique qui se
cristallisent puisqu'ils y ont pas été
adressés encore une fois je vivais à
lakanal délais mais comme ça arrive
quand même souvent pis on veut se mettre
à travailler avec travailleuses du sexe
pour pouvoir payer ça et puis à chaque
ville et à chaque étape du processus si
une vulnérables une vulnérabilité qui
s'accumulent tu es quelqu'un qui par
exemple consomme est beaucoup plus
vulnérable à être agressés dans un
contexte où elle est un toc ce qui est
tout est bon dans un contexte de travail
de prostitution aussi il ya énormément
de vulnérabilités qui peuvent se
finalement s'accumuler et ce qui fait en
sorte qu'on est un peu plus hostile
envers ces personnes le même temps
quelqu'un de complètement que technique
et qui nous dit moi j'ai été victime
d'agressions sexuelles si à la volée
pour voir pour payer quelque chose ou
payer sa drogue et où c'est sûr qu'on va
avoir la difficulté à vivre
de l'empathie s'est alors laissé ses
collègues qui sont souvent échappé qui
sont les plus importantes parce qu'une
politique sinisation il ya un lourd lolo
bagages mais oui tpiy le gie migros
exemple mais effectivement il ya des
facteurs de vulnérabilité très
personnels qui font en sorte que oui
j'ai peut-être possibilité entre les
chefs le disque est une possibilité de
re victimisation plus en plus grande
oui où est ce que on depuis pour les
actes nous écoutent oui même si ça mon
compte instagram essentiellement
maintenant déception pour charpentier ce
que j'ai de nombreux mais c'est long qui
j'étais en train de penser à tête si je
serai peut-être une page facebook avec
toutes mes outils finalement qui sont
qui sont les plus éducatif le je pense à
ça je pense ap la direction de où ça
s'en va tout seul et c'est aussi parce
que les gens avancent nkoulou cifacom
voir un peu où canaliser mon énergie je
veux continuer d'apprendre certains mais
c'est quelque chose c'est un truc c'est
un exercice de vulgarisation j'aime
beaucoup que je trouve essentiel en ce
moment oui tout ce qui est sûr c'est que
tes connaissances sont sont nécessaires
qui sont importantes plus puis à des
gens qui vont être témoins qui vont être
qu'ils vont lire des publications mieux
ses enfants merci infiniment merci